no nobel prizes have been given yet
related to string theory do you think
they will be do you think you have to
have experimental validation or can a
nobel prize be given which i don't think
has been given for quite a long time
for uh
purely sort of theoretical contribution
yeah it certainly as a matter of
historical precedent has been the case
that those who win the prize
have
established investigated
illuminated a demonstrably real quality
of the world
so
gravitational waves the prize was
awarded after they were detected not not
the mathematics of it but the actual
detection of it you know the higgs
particle
you know it was an idea that came from
the 1960s peter higgs and others in fact
and it wasn't until
2012
on july 4th when the announcement came
that this protocol had been detected the
large hadron collider that people viewed
it as eligible for the nobel prize the
idea was there the math was there but
you needed to
confirm it indeed the prize ultimately
was awarded so i'm not surprised
in fact i would have been surprised if a
nobel prize had been awarded in the
arena of string theory because it's far
too
speculative right now it's far too
hypothetical in fact
i am sympathetic to the view
that it really shouldn't be called
string theory it degrades the word
theory
because theory in science of course
means the best available explanation for
the things that we observe in the world
the things that we measure in
experiments about the world
and string theory does not do that at
least not yet so it really should be
the string hypothesis right we're at an
earlier stage of development
and that's not the kind of thing that
nobel prizes should be awarded for
you